simplifica x al cubo elevada a la cuarta
potencia por equis cuadrada elevada a la
quinta potencia para hacer esto usaremos
la propiedad de potenciación de
exponentes en ocasiones denominada la
regla de potencias la cual nos dice que
si tenemos x elevado a la potencia y
esto a la vez elevado a la potencia b
esto es igual a x elevado a la potencia
a por b y para ver porque esto funciona
para probar con un ejemplo no voy a
hacer uno de estos casos que no están
pidiendo voy a hacer un ejemplo más
simple supongamos que tenemos x al
cuadrado y eso elevado al cubo bueno qué
significa esto x cuadrada elevado al
cubo esto significa que estamos
multiplicando x cuadrada por x cuadrada
por x cuadrada estamos multiplicando x
cuadrada por sí misma 3 veces eso es lo
que significa x cuadrada por x 4 x x
cuadrada y esto a que es igual bueno
podemos verlo de dos maneras primero
recordando la regla del producto de
exponentes esto de aquí es x al cuadrado
tres veces es decir x elevado a la 2
22 y esto de aquí es equivalente a x a
la 3 por 2
lo cual es igual a equis a la sexta de
otra manera tú podrías decir oye salió
no entiendo esta regla el producto bueno
entonces fíjate que aquí tenemos que x
cuadrada es equivalente a equis por
equis por otra vez x cuadrada x por
equis y estoy ponía entre paréntesis las
x cuadradas así es que aquí es por x por
equis y que tenemos aquí x x x 6 veces x
x x x x x x x x x x aquí lo que tenemos
es x a la sexta potencia es por eso que
podemos sumar los exponentes de esta
manera
apliquemos entonces la regla de
potencias para esta expresión para
empezar tenemos x al cubo elevado a la
cuarta potencia esto es entonces x a la
3 x 4x a la potencia 12 y eso está x x
al cuadrado elevado a la quinta potencia
y esto es simplemente x a la 2 x 5 x a
la décima potencia y ahora tenemos la
misma base estamos haciendo el producto
podemos simplemente
los exponentes así es que esto de aquí
es igual a equis elevado a la potencia
12 10 o equis elevado a la potencia 22 y
ya hemos terminado